opening day 2021 from historic fenway
park
the red sox take on the baltimore
orioles in game one
red sox starter native aldi yeah nate he
deserves this ball
second year in a row starting his season
off against baltimore
he had a nice year last year here's a
special moment for number 16
we saw in the spring when the pirates
came out of the dugout and
a slap on the back of christian vasquez
the catcher as he
welcomed trey mancini back and everybody
knows his story
trey salutes some fans on hand
and that one hooked debra's has it the
second one on the first
and a double play as dalbeck holds on to
the bag
for the twin killing john means
left-hander scheduled opening day
starter a year ago wasn't able to go
goes the other way for a base hit into
right field so hernandez is quickly
aboard
well that is so nicely done right there
angle if you can really see yeah whether
he
definitely came off the bag whether the
glove was on him
and he's out of there well a break for
the orioles
so kk hernandez who lost contact with
the bag
trying to get back to first ruled out
two down and now nobody on
cut on and miss that was a tough one up
and away to fan hayes and they're two
out
or riding fastball he's got no chance
that ball's out of the strike zone and
that's exactly what you want to do
to get a guy to chase this is when
xander got to first base
reaching on the error look at this oh
that's cool trey mancini
being welcomed back
breaking ball right field coming hard
santander
oh ruiz with a nice play going out over
the shoulder
santander i don't think he was going to
get there so there's a guy making his
major league debut at second base
as a starter that's a pretty special
play it really is
oh two changeup bottom swinging perfect
pitch what a sequence
steps toward third kicks and deals and a
swing and a miss there it is
dulbeck whips through a changeup that
was placed beautifully
on the outside corner and means picks up
his second strikeout
he goes after you throw strikes
cut on and miss as he climbed the ladder
he strikes out
mount castle
ocon on the way and he got him so
bogart's down on strikes
red sox with only one hit so far no
score
as we head to the fifth
climbing that ladder again he strikes
out hayes for the second time
one out
one two and he got him on strikes well
up and in and then i mean just a little
extra so we saw 91
first three innings and right here look
at the backspin little four seam
fastball
can't catch up and a 2-2
cut on and missed he put him away so one
big first down here in the sixth inning
here's andres now making his red sox
debut last season with the angels
good opportunity here two on one down
santander
hit hard right side off of hernandez
scrambling won't have a play
and everybody's safe andres to mount
castle
hit well way back
up over and off the monster
two two-run score mob castle in second
with a two rbi double when the orioles
break on top two nothing
well you just saw what we saw in 2020
and that is
you know you you get pitched too i
thought he'd throw him another cutter he
tries to throw him a fastball look at
this pitch it's up and in
able to keep the hands in and then
welcome
to fenway park the green monster
and that is gonna be in there for strike
three no argument from ruiz
and a big punch out number two
probably have the seventh inning in him
if he can take care of business here and
i think he has
popped up right side
[Applause]
a little trouble with the easy one he
catches the tough ones but down in order
they go orioles lead at two nothing
2-2 pitch right side
ruiz with a dive whoa he's flashing some
leather he's made
terrific plays on two pop-ups and he
lays out there to get the quick alex
verdugo
well you would have thought he's played
second base his whole career
i mean look at that jump what a grain
angle right there
ruiz making a statement that brandon
hyde is the manager of the day for
starting on the second base right but
you all wondered how's this gonna work
good battle now means and jd martinez
got him and throws it right by him nine
pitches on the at bat
yeah if you're brandon hyatt and you're
saying is he getting tired well nope
93. he's only thrown about three balls
with this kind of velocity and right
here
in the seventh inning able to throw it
right by martinez strike two balls no
strikes
that's a fair ball now
only in fenway would you not be able to
get to third base on that but that
little extension down there keeps it on
the infield so tree mancini with a base
hit back to back hits
mullins and mancini and the orioles have
something going in the eighth
[Applause]
right side it's into right field base
hit mullins around
third heading to the plate and he's in
now they got mancini hung up between
second and third
and nobody there nobody there so craze
there
santander who was basically parked on
second tagged out but
run in and the orioles lead it three
nothing anthony santander with an rbi
basically
kind of wondering where kk hernandez was
good oh he got him he got him looking a
beauty on the outside corner so
tanner scott couple of walks but a
couple of big strikeouts
1-1 it's that ball hard that's going to
keep on rolling on the grass the track
up against the wall jd martinez digging
for two and he is in there he's got
himself a double
red sox finally get this second hit boy
he was hustling to get that double man
started thinking about it i'm the last
out of the ball game i got to get a
second
a little flare and that's the ball game
as anthony santander finishes off
what must be one of the greatest
pitching performances on opening day
history for the orioles